[S01] 你有没有想过一个呃极其日常的瞬间就是你在手机上刚修改了日历里的一个会议时间转过头在电脑上打开网页瞬间就能看到最新的安排
[S02] 嗯，一切都显得那么理所当然，对吧？
[S01] 没错，非常顺滑。但是你有没有想过，如果就在你修改完的那一秒，手机突然断网了，会发生什么？
[S02] 或者是地球另一端的同事啊，刚好也在修改同一个会议的时间。
[S01] 对，那后台绝对乱套了。所以，欢迎你加入我们今天的深度探索。在这里，我们要揭开那些日常科技背后隐秘的运作法则。
[S02] 是一次非常烧脑的旅程。
[S01] 绝对的。今天为了弄清楚这一切，我们将深入挖掘软件工程领域的一本圣经，也就是大名鼎鼎的《设计数据密集型应用》，很多人管它叫 DDIA。
[S02] 这本书那个确实把数据系统的底裤都给扒光了。
[S01] 哈哈，对，我们今天的使命很简单，就是要向你揭秘。当系统需要把你发的一条社交动态或者一个文档的修改，完美地保存在全球各地的几十台机器上时，工程师们究竟面临着怎样疯狂的挑战？
[S02] 还有他们是如何就是如何防止你的数据撕裂时空的？这确实是一个让人着迷的领域。
[S01] 是啊。
[S02] 因为我们平时总有一种错觉，觉得数据嘛就像放在抽屉里的文件，放进去它就安安静静地待在那儿了。
[S01] 锁上抽屉就万事大吉了。
[S02] 呃，其实在真实的分布式系统世界里，完全不是这样。为了保证速度，也为了防止某台机器突然坏掉，导致数据彻底丢失。同一份数据必须在世界各地的服务器上拥有很多个分身。
[S01] 狡兔三窟嘛。
[S02] 对，而一旦有了分身，真正的噩梦就开始了。你如何让所有的分身在任何时刻都保持绝对的步调一致？
[S01] 这就好比你给几百个朋友发同一条消息，怎么保证所有人看到的版本都是一模一样的？
[S02] 没错，太难了。
[S01] 所以为了解决这个同步的问题，如果我们顺着人的直觉来想，最简单的方案就是找一个老大来拍板。
[S02] 嗯，也是最传统的做法。
[S01] 这就引出了我们要探讨的第一种架构设计，叫做单主复制。也就是所有的写入操作，不管你是在纽约还是在北京，都必须经过这个唯一的领导者，然后由他把变更的指令下发给底下的追随者。
[S02] 为了让大家更直观的感受，那个我们可以把它想象成一个厨房，主厨就是那个领导者，底下的帮厨就是追随者。
[S01] 这个厨房的类比非常贴切，有主厨和帮厨，那就立刻引出了一个系统里最经典的困境，同步还是异步？
[S02] 对，这就非常关键了。
[S01] 如果主厨每切一刀都要死死盯着所有的帮厨，确认大家都切完同样的一刀了，他才敢去切下一刀，这就叫同步复制。
[S02] 它的好处是绝对安全。万一主厨突然晕倒了，任何一个帮厨都能立刻顶上，因为大家手里的进度呃是一模一样的。
[S01] 但代价就是极其低效。只要有一个帮厨去上了个洗手间，或者手脚慢了一点，
[S02] 整个厨房的运作就得完全停摆，所有人都在等他。
[S01] 对啊，所以现实中如果是那种每秒要处理千万次请求的大型网站，绝对不可能等所有帮厨确认，对吧？
[S02] 绝对不可能。所以现实中的数据库通常会妥协，选择异步复制，也就是主厨只管自己疯狂的切菜，切完就把菜谱往后一扔。
[S01] 让帮厨自己去捡。
[S02] 对，帮厨们在后面尽力跟上，主厨根本不在乎帮厨现在切到哪一步了。
[S01] 但这就引出了一个大问题，如果帮厨跟不上进度呢？其实这就是你我每一个普通人在上网时都可能遇到过的灵异事件。
[S02] 灵异事件这个词很准。
[S01] 比如你肯定经历过这种事，你在社交媒体上刚发完一条长篇大论，满心欢喜地刷新页面，结果发现帖子不见了。
[S02] 哈哈，然后吓出一身冷汗。
[S01] 对，以为自己被系统封号了，或者触发了什么违禁词，结果过了几秒钟，你再刷新一次，它又神秘地出现了。
[S02] 这就是异步复制带来的第一种典型异常，专业术语叫读己之写异常。
[S01] 读己之写，也就是读到自己写的东西。
[S02] 没错，当你点击发送的那一刻，你的帖子被写入了主厨节点。但是当你紧接着刷新页面去读取时，系统的负载均衡器很不巧的把你分配到了一个帮厨节点上。
[S01] 而那个帮厨还没抄完笔记？
[S02] 对，还没抄完主厨最新菜谱。所以在他的世界里，你的帖子压根儿不存在。
[S01] 难怪，那系统怎么解决这个问题？总不能弹窗告诉用户，请你耐心等帮厨抄完吧。
[S02] 肯定不行，系统必须在架构上打补丁。比如设定一个硬性规则，如果你查看的是你自己的个人主页，系统就强制让你直接去问主厨。如果是看别人的主页，那再去问帮厨。
[S01] 哇，这招很聪明，巧妙地用规则掩盖了物理时间差。
[S02] 算是障眼法吧，但这只是最基础的异常。还有一种更让人抓狂的叫做单调读异常。在这个异常里，你会亲眼目睹时间倒流。
[S01] 等等，时间倒流，这听起来就像科幻小说了。
[S02] 其实不罕见。你可以想象这样一个场景，你正在关注一场非常激烈的世界杯决赛比分。你第一次刷新页面，请求落到了一个跟得比较快的帮厨节点上。
[S01] 嗯，这时候比分是多少？
[S02] 你看到比分变成了一点零，主队进球了，你非常激动，过了两秒，你又刷新了一次，这次请求不巧落到了一个有严重网络延迟的帮厨节点上。
[S01] 完了，他的进度是落后的。
[S02] 对，在他的世界线里，进球这个事还没发生，于是你眼睁睁看到比分变回了零点零。
[S01] 哇，如果我是赌球的，我绝对会把手机砸了。
[S02] 呵呵，对你来说，你就是先看到了未来，然后又瞬间回到了过去。
[S01] 这还没完。如果说时间倒流让人抓狂，那接下来的第三种异常就直接摧毁因果律了，这就是一致前缀读异常。
[S02] 呃，这个确实最头疼。
[S01] 这里我必须提一下资料里那个极其经典的例子。想象一段对话，观察者先听到了K夫人的回答，通常大约十秒钟，然后才听到PONZ先生提出的问题，你能看到多远的未来？
[S02] 哈哈，这在分布式系统里是极其典型的因果关系错乱。
[S01] 如果把这个场景带入到大家常用的微信或者群聊里，就更好理解了。一个人问，你要嫁给我吗？另一个人回答，我愿意。
[S02] 但由于整个系统非常庞大，数据被分散存在不同的机器上，PONZ先生发出的问题被存入了一个网络极其拥堵的server分区。
[S01] 而K夫人的回答，走了一条畅通无阻的快车道。
[S02] 没错，作为旁观者的你，同时从这两个分区拉取聊天日志，结果就是你先看到了答案，后看到了问题。
[S01] 所以啊，单主厨这个主厨真的是太难当了，它不仅是个单点瓶颈，一旦它出了意外，整个厨房得乱作一团，而且还要忍受帮厨们因为动作慢导致的各种时空错乱。
[S02] 是的，维护秩序的成本太高了。
[S01] 既然找一个老大有这么多麻烦，那最顺理成章的下一步就是为什么我们不顾两个老大呢？
[S02] 多找几个主厨。
[S01] 对啊，如果北京的厨房太远，我们就在纽约再建一个厨房，各自配一个主厨。
[S02] 非常符合逻辑的推演。这就进入了第二种主流架构，也就是多主复制。顾名思义就是有多个节点都可以直接接受用户的写入请求。
[S01] 这种在跨国公司里应该很常见吧。
[S02] 非常常见，特别是跨地域运行的全球化应用。如果你在纽约，你每次修稿数据都要等北京的服务器确认，那个物理距离带来的延迟，现代互联网用户是绝对无法忍受的。
[S01] 会卡到让人怀疑人生。
[S02] 所以纽约有一个领导者，北京也有一个领导者，他们各自先快速处理本地的请求，然后在后台伊布里交换彼此的笔记。
[S01] 懂了，其实这也不仅仅是大公司的专利，我们每天都在不知不觉地使用多主架构。
[S02] 比如呢？
[S01] 比如那些主打离线优先的应用啊，像你在高铁上没有信号的时候，用文档软件打字，或者在手机日历上添加日程。在那个断网的瞬间，你的手机本身就变成了一个临时的主厨。
[S02] 对，本地节点当家做主。
[S01] 你在本地尽情修改，等有了网络，他再去跟云端的主厨交换数据。
[S02] 但这听起来像是一个完美的乌托邦，直到我们遇到了那个最可怕的噩梦。
[S01] 也就是写入冲突。
[S02] 写入冲突，这是多主架构的阿克利罗斯之种。假设你和你的同事正在协作编辑同一个文档，你在纽约的主厨那里把标题改成了A,他在北京的主厨那里把标题改成了B.两个主厨在后台一交换笔记傻眼了，到底听谁的？
[S01] 是啊，这怎么判定？解决冲突最简单的策略是什么？
[S02] 最简单粗暴的策略叫做LWW,也就是最后写入胜利。
[S01] 最后写入胜利。
[S02] 对，系统会给每一次写入操作都打上一个精确到毫秒的时间戳。当冲突发生时，数据库就背比时间戳，谁的时间更靠后，谁就赢。
[S01] 那另一个人修改的呢？
[S02] 直接悄无声息地丢弃掉。
[S01] 哼，等等，稍等一下，这听起来极度不靠谱啊。意思是数据库为了保持它内部所谓的绝对一致，会偷偷摸摸地删掉其中一个用户的成功操作，这难道不会造成巨大的灾难吗？
[S02] 确实会。
[S01] 这就好比我们俩同时向同一个联名账户里存钱，系统为了避免冲突，直接把我的钱抹零了。
[S02] 你的敏锐度非常高，这确实是分布式系统中的一个呃极其残酷的取舍。在很多场景下，LWW确实会导致严重的数据丢失。
[S01] 那为什么还要用它？
[S02] 因为它极其简单，而且能绝对保证所有副本最终一定能达成一致。如果你的应用场景只是更新用户的最后一次登录时间，那丢弃几毫秒前的记录完全无伤大雅。
[S01] 但如果是购物车或者协作文档，LWW就是一场彻底的灾难了。
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 说到购物车，资料里那个经典的Amazon购物车异常，简直让人哭笑不得。当你的手机和电脑上的购物车发生冲突时，如果系统的合并策略稍微偷点懒，比如只是简单的取个并集，你知道会发生什么吗？
[S02] 很多听众可能都遇到过类似的灵异事件。
[S01] 假设你在手机上把一本你不想要的书移出了购物车，但同时你的电脑在后台做了一次自动的并发同步，系统一对比，发现电脑的购物车里有这本书，手机的没有取并集一合并，好家伙。
[S02] 书又回来了。
[S01] 对，这本被你删掉的书又像僵尸一样死而复生了，硬生生逼着你买单。
[S02] 这个例子完美展示了要想在多主架构下自动解决冲突，需要极其高超的智慧，特别是像文本编辑这种需要精确到字符层面的数据，工程师们发明了更高级的武器，比如操作变换，也就是OT以及无冲突复制数据类型，称简称CRDT。
[S01] 这里我们必须得把那个把单字ice变成nice,然后再加感叹号的例子给揉碎了讲一讲，因为它太巧妙了。
[S02] 这个例子很经典。
[S01] 听众朋友们，你可以想象一下，现在屏幕上有一个词ice，冰块的冰，你想把它变成nice美好，所以你在最前面，也就是索引位置零的地方插入了一个字母N。
[S02] 但这同时我在地球另一端想把它变成感叹语ice,所以我跑到最后面，也就是索引位置三的地方插入了一个感叹号。
[S01] 这时候冲突就来了。如果系统只是像刻板的机器一样记录索引位置，用户A在索引零插入N,用户B在索引三插入感叹号。
[S02] 当系统试图合并时，它先执行你的操作，变成了nice.这时候原来在索引三的那个空位，因为前面挤进来一个N,已经被字母E占有了。
[S01] 如果系统盲目地继续执行你的指令，在索引三插入感叹号，结果就会变成nice点一。
[S02] 完全乱套了，单词被生生劈开了。
[S01] 哇，所以这就是为什么同时编辑文档那么难，那OT是怎么解决这个问题呢？
[S02] OT的核心在于变换。当系统准备应用我的在索引三插入感叹号的操作时，它会敏锐地察觉到等等。在执行这个动作之前，另一个人已经在前面插入了一个字母。
[S01] 系统意识到了前面的位置变动。
[S02] 对，于是OT引擎会自动把我的指令进行变换，把插入位置从三悄悄向后顺延到了四，这样感叹号就完美的落在了nice的最后面。
[S01] 这是一种基于相对位置的动态计算，很聪明，但是这听起来计算量极其庞大啊，那CRDT呢？我听说这是一种完全不同的思路。
[S02] 是的，CRDT走的是一条更加颠覆的路线，它干脆放弃了索引这个概念。在CRDT的世界里，它给每一个字母都颁发了一个全宇宙唯一的身份ID,而且这个ID带有排序功能。
[S01] 给字母发身份证。
[S02] 对，比如I的ID是一A,C是二A,一是三A.
[S01] 啊，我明白了，所以当我想要在最前面插入N的时候，系统不是记录在位置零插入，而是记录在身份为一A的字符前面插入N.
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 而你要插入感叹号，系统记录的是在身份为三A的字符后面插入。这样一来，我问系统先处理谁的指令，网络怎么乱序，系统都能精准地把它们安插在正确的位置。
[S02] 完全不需要像OT那样费尽心思去计算位置偏移，这就是给数据赋予绝对坐标的魅力。但是不管是OT还是CRDT,都在说明一件事。
[S01] 什么事？
[S02] 让多个领导者互相协商处理冲突，是一件极其耗费心智和算力的事情。
[S01] 确实，既然协调多个领导者这么让人头疼，那干脆我们一不做二不休，连领导者都不要了。
[S02] 哈哈，直接掀桌子。
[S01] 对，彻底走向无政府状态会怎样？这就带领我们进入了今天最疯狂的第三个阵营，也就是无主复制，或者叫Dynamo风格架构。
[S02] 在无主架构里，人人平等，没有任何节点拥有特权，也不存在什么主厨和帮厨。
[S01] 那怎么写入数据？
[S02] 当你作为一个客端想要写入数据时，你不会去找什么领导，而是直接把你的数据像撒网一样，同时丢给系统里的所有节点。
[S01] 如果有的节点刚好断网了呢？
[S02] 无所谓，只要有足够多的节点接受到了数据，这次写入就算成功了。
[S01] 等等，如果没有任何领导者来拍板，什么是真相？那你怎么知道你读到的数据是不是最新的？如果我运气不好，刚好向那个错过了更新的节点查询数据怎么办？
[S02] 这就是无主架构的核心魔法所在了。系统通过一种叫做仲裁的机制，quorum来保证你总能读到最新的真相。
[S01] 仲裁这个概念听起来有点抽象，呃，让我试试用一个日常的逻辑来拆解一下。
[S02] 你试试。
[S01] 假设系统里一共有三个节点，如果我每次写入数据都必须确保至少有两个节点成功记录了。
[S02] 嗯，这是写入的前提。
[S01] 然后我每次读取数据也必须同时向至少两个节点去询问，对吧？因为二加二等于四大于总数三，所以无论我怎么挑，我询问的那两个节点里，绝对必然包含了至少一个拥有最新数据的节点，这是基础的数学集合重叠原理。
[S02] 你完全抓住了本质，这就是分布式系统里著名的W加R大于N公式。只要写入和读取的节点集合有交集，那个交集里的节点就是掌握最新真相的证人。
[S01] 这太巧妙了，但那些宕机后重新上线的节点怎么办？他们手里的数据是旧的，难道就让他们一直戳下去吗？
[S02] 当然不会，无主系统有很强的自我愈合能力，最常见的一种叫独修复。
[S01] 怎么个修复法？
[S02] 比如你刚才同时向两个节点读取数据，节点A告诉你比分是一点零，节点B告诉你比分是零点零，客端对比时间戳发现A是最新的，于是他把一点零返回给你的同时，会顺手向B发送一个更新指令。
[S01] 嘿，你落后了，赶紧把比分改成一点零。
[S02] 对，这就叫独修复。大家在互相借阅笔记的过程中，顺手帮你纠错。
[S01] 这种互帮互复制设计真的很有机。但是在这种彻底无政府，大家同时接受数据的环境里，其实隐藏着一个终极的哲学危机。
[S02] 哲学危机。
[S01] 对啊，如果没有任何人排队，也没有领导者来盖绝对的时间戳。那到底什么叫同时发生？或者用专业名字说，什么叫并发？在我们的常识里，并发就是两件事在时钟上的同一秒钟发生。
[S02] 这恰恰是分布式系统里最烦直觉的一点。在分布式系统里，由于每台机器的时钟都可能有一点点误差，物理时间是极其不可靠的，所以判断并发根本不看绝对时间。
[S01] 那看什么？
[S02] 并发真正的定义是彼此不知道对方的存在。
[S01] 彼此不知道对方的存在。
[S02] 对，也就是没有因果上的前后继承关系。就算两件事在地球的物理时间上相隔了一整天，只要他们在修改数据时，都没有基于对方修改过后的状态进行，哪怕隔了二十四小时，在数据库眼里，他们就是并发的。
[S01] 这个概念，资料里的那个购物车因果依赖图展现得极其生动。
[S02] 我们可以还原一下那个场景。
[S01] 假设你想买早餐，客户一往购物车里加了一盒牛奶，系统记录下来，并给这个状态打了个唯一的版本号。接着客户二的网络有点问题，他在完全不知道购物车里已经有牛奶的情况下，往里面加了鸡蛋。
[S02] 这个时候数据库拿到这两条指令就懵了。
[S01] 对，他发现鸡蛋并不是在牛奶的基础上添加的，这两个动作互相不知道对方，所以数据库绝对不会擅作主张，用鸡蛋去覆盖牛奶。
[S02] 没错，数据库会把牛奶和鸡蛋作为两个平行的兄弟版本同时保留下来。系统会使用一种叫做版本向量的技术来追踪这种复杂的血缘关系。
[S01] 就像是数据的一张精密的族谱。
[S02] 对，一张族谱。
[S01] 那这族谱到底怎么用呢？假设客户一随后又想加面粉，他在提交面粉的时候，必须带上之前的版本号，告诉系统，嘿，我是基于已经有牛奶的那个版本往里加面粉的。
[S02] 系统一听懂了，面粉是牛奶的合法后代，所以系统可以安全地用牛奶加面粉覆盖掉原来的牛奶。
[S01] 但是，系统依然会保留那颗孤立的鸡蛋。
[S02] 因为鸡蛋是另一条世界线上的产物，直到最后当你要结账的时候，系统会把这两个兄弟版本一起丢给你的手机，让客端在本地把它们核定成牛奶、面粉、鸡蛋。
[S01] 呵呵，最后一次性写回数据库。
[S02] 非常精彩的推演。版本向量确保了系统永远不会弄丢任何一次没有因果关系的写入。
[S01] 那么把我们今天聊的这一切拼凑起来，到底意味着什么？我们今天穿越了数据复制的三大阵营，单主复制用独裁换来了秩序，但代价是无聊的瓶颈和各种时空错乱的幻觉。呵呵。
[S02] 多主复制让全球异地协作成为可能，却让我们陷入了冲突合并的无尽泥潭。
[S01] 而无主复制干脆放弃了领导者，用仲裁公式和版本向量在混乱中寻找交集。这不仅是技术的演进，更像是在这三个极端之间寻找平衡点。
[S02] 确实在这个世界里，永远没有完美的标准答案，只有可用性、延迟和一致性之间永恒的权衡。
[S01] 这是个艰难的三角恋。
[S02] 哈，是的。如果你仔细想象，今天我们讨论的所有这些复杂的架构、协议和算法，其实都在试图解决同一个问题，反抗物理学的基本限制。
[S01] 物理限制。
[S02] 对，系统判定并发不依赖于绝对时间，这其实跟物理学中的狭义相对论不谋而合。信息传播的速度不可能超过光速，只要信息还没有传到你这里，哪怕它在宇宙的另一端已经发生了一万年。
[S01] 对你来说，它也是未知的并发的。
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 这给我们的探索留下了一个巨大且迷人的悬念。我们人类目前在地球上的网络延迟，大概也就是几十到几百毫秒。现代的这些数据库用尽了各种奇技淫巧，勉强还能应付得过来。
[S02] 算是勉强及格。但想象一下，几十年后，如果我们在火星建立了殖民地，地球与火星之间的通信，哪怕是以光速传播，单程也需要几分钟到几十分钟。
[S01] 呃，在那种延迟尺度下，同时这个词彻底失去了意义。
[S02] 绝对的。当你和你在火星上的朋友试图在同一个云文档里编辑同一行文字时，基于我们今天聊的这些复制法则，它还能奏效吗？恐怕不行了。Lww会导致大规模的数据被无情抹除，而CRDT可能会因为积累了海量的兄弟版本，让内存彻底崩溃。
[S01] 如果光速这道物理墙是不可逾越的，那未来的新技术数据库该如何运作？我们是否需要一种全新的数据物理学？
[S02] 这是一个留给未来的超级难题。
[S01] 这儿的问题就留给正在收听的你。在下一次你的APP卡顿了半秒钟的瞬间去独自咀嚼吧，感谢你的陪伴，我们下次再见。